hold your spoon high over your ice cream
cake
and then drizzle okay
oh that that you got to get it on the
cake
yeah i mean it's on the cake it's just
my caramel took a dump on the cake
[Music]
hey guys it's mike chan welcome to
another episode of cone heads the
coolest
swedish show on the internet it seems
nowadays whenever you watch a video of a
knife cutting into basically any object
it turns out to be a cake
but today we're gonna switch that around
what if we're cutting into a cake and it
turns out to be ice cream
the ice cream cake is really one of the
greatest mash-ups in
culinary history and to join me on this
little fun adventure
we have yolanda [ __ ] the host of the
so popular how to kick it youtube
channel yolanda how you doing
i'm good mike how are you i'm ready for
this first time i had ice cream cake
it was i i think baskin robbins or
something and
blew my mind i mean i love cake and i
love ice cream but to have those
things together it's it's one of the
greatest memories of my childhood
i'm with you i love ice cream cake and
everyone always buys me an ice cream
cake for my birthday
because no one wants to bake me a cake
which i understand
right now there's so many everyday
objects being made into cakes why do you
think there's a fascination
about that like why why do people want
to bite into like a boot
or something i don't know and what's
funny is i've been a cake decorator for
22
years when i had clients i always wanted
to encourage them to get
objects and they never wanted that they
always wanted tears and typical cakes
and so that's why on the channel i've
made so many weird
objects i think people are fascinated by
the transformation
you know i start with a cake pan of cake
and at the end you see a roasted turkey
i think
any type of transformation is
fascinating to people you are teaching
me how to make
an ice cream cake today i'm gonna walk
you through it you're gonna do this all
the time
because it's so simple i know you know
how to cake it but
you ready to ice cream it yes let's ice
cream it
let's do it let's go
all right yolanda i got all the stuff
you told me to get i see a lot of candy
bars which i'm not complaining
what's step one step one is we're gonna
make our crust
and oreo crust in our spring form pen so
you need oreo crumbs you need some
butter
and then of course you need your pan
butter melted
oreos crumble not by me what's next
next we're going to pour our butter into
our oreo crumbs
and then we're going to stir it together
you just want to stir everything so that
the crumbs are completely coated in
butter i use chopsticks for everything
oh that's awesome
what do we do with this once it's all
saturated so now you have your beautiful
crumbs you can pour them into your
springform
pan and this is going to make a really
nice crust i also love this kind of
crust because i'm a huge fan of like
different textures so you're going to
get a nice crunchy crust
soft ice cream and then little surprises
of chocolate bar and goodies inside
okay so we can put our crust aside and
now we're gonna chop
chocolate bars chocolate bars all of
them yeah
all of them it's a lot of chocolate
[Music]
so my favorite chocolate bars are kitkat
score and then snickers and then i
wanted to double
up on the oreos so i have like mini
oreos
you know it doesn't have to be fine but
you want little bite-sized pieces
i love the sound of chopping kitkat it
is very satisfying
it is it is very asmr-ish
[Music]
so next is score yeah so you can just
sort of slice
through it i love the crunch i love the
coffee inside
it's like a chocolate buffet so now we
can move on to ice cream
the star of the show really let's do it
[Music]
ice cream is out candy bars are chopped
how do we put this together okay the
next thing we have to do is take our ice
cream out of the container
i like to put it in a bowl and just make
sure it's soft enough to spread
in the pan what flavor you got i have
chocolate vanilla and salted caramel
so i'm gonna put chocolate in first
right on top of my crust
and you just wanna put it right in the
center
and then use your spatula to help spread
it around we're trying to create
a layer of ice cream so once you have
your first
layer of ice cream i'm gonna go in with
kit kat i feel kit kat goes well with
chocolate ice cream
that's what i'm doing i didn't know kit
kat could be used this way i'm so happy
and then once you're satisfied with the
amount of kitkat i'm gonna start to add
my caramel ice cream on top
so i spread my caramel yes my chocolate
ice cream mixed in a little with it but
that's just
even more delicious i'm gonna put score
on my caramel ice cream
oh i got a kitkat in there nope you had
your turn
i'm gonna add the vanilla right on top
and this one i'm going to sort of create
some swirls
on the top of the cake like i don't want
it to be as flat so so mine looks like
a melted mess right now okay so listen
whenever you feel like your cake looks
messy
the term is rustic just tell people
this is a rustic artisanal ice cream
cake
gotcha so now i'm gonna top this with
snickers and then of course
my little oreos so my snickers i'm just
gonna pile it on because i want this to
look like
you just want to dig in
[Music]
all right yolanda you gotta you gotta
critique my rustic
creation here okay let me see oh it's
beautiful
i even love the drips around the side of
the pan
do you have some caramel i do i have a
thing for caramel
i even have a special voice when i use
caramel
girl you know i love caramel girl
you know caramel makes everything better
okay so you can use a spoon and when you
use a spoon
you just want to really lift it and then
with the height you'll be able to get a
nice drizzle
okay oh that that
you got to get it on the cake yeah i
mean it's on the cake
it's just like caramel took a dump on
the cake
it's okay so now i'm just gonna drizzle
my caramel across the top and it's kind
of like
added glue to hold everything down
plus flavor of course yes oh yes
girl you look good
now we have to get these cakes in the
freezer like asap
how long are we putting these in the
freezer for
i'm gonna say half an hour but it's
important that we check and see that
it's frozen and not drippy anymore
let's go to the freezer and i'll see you
soon okay all right
all right yolanda i've been i've been
pretty nervous this past 30 minutes
how do you think i did i mean this thing
is less droopy now so that's always good
some of mine like melted out the bottom
of the pan
but it seems frozen now do it slowly you
don't want to
shock the ice cream cake i mean it looks
like it went through a little earthquake
but
oh mine is not frozen
okay i'm gonna take a break from being
my usual uptight self
i'm going to let it go and we're going
to cut this and eat it
because it's rustic and it's going to
taste good it's an ice cream are you
ready
yes
like frosty the snowman died or
something but yeah
the crust is keeping it together so i've
got oh and now i just dropped the slice
upside this is amazing i'm really
i'm doing my best here okay i'm waiting
for you mike
you've got a spoon here we go okay a
toast
cheers
it's delicious i don't even care about
how it looks right now
i got oreo and score and coffee and
caramel
and vanilla all in one bite yeah no that
texture is awesome you got a crumpled
oreos and then the chewy caramel
crunch from the other oreos this is a
really easy
and fun way to eat some ice cream
i mean i'm okay with it being like this
like look it's not
the prettiest and it's not the most
stable but
i mean just drop it on your plate
and try to eat it as fast as possible
thank you again so much for joining me
yolanda
guys definitely check out yolanda's
channel how to cake it
this has been such a vacation for me
normally i'm all uptight
spending four days making a cake making
it look as perfect as i can
and i'm never happy and look at me now
i've just got a
an ice cream swamp in front of me and
i'm happy
thank you so much for watching see you
next time
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you